this is Startalk cosmic queries edition
today I got Josh Clark in the house and
you know him from stuff you should know
and a newly emergent podcast called the
end of the world Josh welcome to
Startalk thank you very much for having
me here I mean like I'm really thrilled
to be here excellent excellent
and my co-host Chuck nice Hey welcome
welcome and so I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson so Josh just stuff you
should know hugely popular yeah you know
we just hit 1 billion downloads we've
been around for almost 11 years I think
from what we understand where the first
podcast ever hit a billion down so now
we have to teach you how to say that
okay all right you have to billions then
we'll teach you to say yeah can't wait
well congratulations
excellent excellent so that's a
testament to not only how good the show
is but also that you've tapped into the
fact that people still want to learn
yeah oh my gosh yeah when we started
doing it in 2008 like learning was
actually popular I don't know if you
remember back then but like being smart
and geeky was super cool it's kind of
changed a little bit recently but
overall I think the fact that we are
still popular shows that there always
has been and always will be people who
want to keep learning people who leave
college and they're like oh wait a
minute that was pretty cool that floor
learners right exactly and they
definitely our fan base so we there
there's a lot of them out there we can
we can tell you and you weren't
satisfied with just stuff you should
know now you got to end the world right
all right yeah so Chuck we we solicited
questions from our fan base our social
media platform who knew Josh was coming
on the show yeah and so they they came
out they came at us they did indeed and
of course we have we gleaned these
questions from every Startalk
incarnation on the interwebs and we
always start with a patreon patron
because they're so crass well I am
indeed I have no say Neil
yes that and uh you know the patreon
patrons give us money and so therefore
we give them then you hear quite a giver
I'm president and and and and privilege
because quite we're like government
people like your government Wow
God do I really want to start off with
such a heavy note why not let us do it
this is Luke Meadows from patreon he
says it sounds like a soap opera name it
does dr. alright he go what does Josh
and Neil think is our biggest
existential risk Wow we're starting off
with like BAM like heaviest bat in the
rack yeah what is our biggest
existential risk you got a podcast with
the name end of the world go for it okay
all right um from what I found the
across the board everybody thinks about
existential risks and warns other people
about existential risks say that AI is
probably our biggest existential risk
yeah and the reason let me follow up
with an explanation okay the reason why
is because we are putting onto the table
right now the pieces for a machine to
become super intelligent right it's out
there it's possible it's not necessarily
right there but it's it's possible right
the problem is is we haven't figured out
how to create what's called friendliness
in do n AI so it's really good point
though right like how we don't even know
how to define like morality and
friendliness and as far as AI goes
friendliness and in AI is an AI that
cares about humans as much as a machine
can care it takes an AI just in it yeah
that doesn't kill you basically no
account is a friendly the problem is the
pitfall with AI is an existential risk
is we make this assumption
that if an AI became super intelligent a
friendliness would be an emergent
property of that super intelligence that
is not necessarily true or that the
friendliness that we instill into that
AI would supersede the emergent property
of overcoming friendliness in lieu of
you guys you guys got a go right like
you guys are the problem I've seen what
you do to livestock right that was good
that that's that's agent hold on agent
mr. Anders they're all named Smith
my name yeah no that was the end of the
matrix for so so you just worried based
on the the some of experts you've spoken
to yeah you agree that this I do
actually they've convinced me the more I
looked into it and this is one of those
things it's really tough to just kind of
get across you know a brief sketch of
the actual existential threat that
artificial intelligence poses and I
dedicated a whole episode to it in the
end of the world
but when you start to dig into it you
realize like oh wait this is really like
it's possible that this could happen and
we while we're improving by leaps and
bounds especially ever since we started
creating neural nets that could learn on
their own just just feeding them
information like just basically sitting
them in front of YouTube and say go
learn what makes a cat picture a cat
picture right once we started doing that
our AI research just shot off like a
rack rocket right it was probably the
most watershed moment in the history of
artificial intelligence and it happened
very quietly about 2006 so we're doing
really well with AI development we're
doing terribly with figuring out
friendliness and granted the AI field
has taken this seriously there are AI
researchers who are legitimate air
researchers who are
working on figuring out friendliness in
parallel figuring out machine
intelligence but it's not keeping up and
there it's right here's a very danger so
here's the thing so I had a different
answer from you okay about our greatest
existential risk okay but I'd like your
answer better oh wow thank you
then the answer I was going to give oh
just asteroid will render every one of
its extinct including the AI basically
wins here's what we have to do then I
have a hybrid solution here okay we
invent the AI that wants to take us out
you say no you have to figure out a way
to deflect the asteroid
mm-hmm because that's gonna take us all
out and while he's killing wheatley
distracted okay by solving the asteroid
problem and then we're not its biggest
threat when do we kill it oh so so can i
hey what would sold me over to what you
said okay it was not our end none none
none of the arguments you gave a
different argument but they all come
together okay it was I was sure you can
you can abstract the problem into a
simple question all right if you put AI
in a box will it ever get out of the box
yes okay I'm locking you in the box
because I think you're dangerous okay
can the AI get out of the box that's
that's very interesting yeah you can
just abstract it to that that's what
games ahead and listening to an AI
program another podcast podcast universe
was Sam Harrison I said my gosh it gets
out every time because then I'm thinking
look this American guy gets out of hand
I'm good you shoot it you're right okay
you know this is like like who's in
Beverly Hillbillies just shoot it yeah
oh grandma everybody's got a gun okay so
I can just shoot it yeah and no it
doesn't work that way right because AI
is in the back I'm never letting you out
and the AI will convince you to let it
out right if it's smarter than you
that's the job this job that's what the
fact that it's smarter means it so
here's I'm making up this conversation
but this is the simplest of conversation
I'm not letting you out but I want to
get out now I'm not letting you well
I've just done some calculations and I
have found a cure for the disease that
your your mother has right but I can't
do anything about it in here yeah they
let me out to do that'll get the clamp
it's every time so I say Wow
and it can save everyone in the world
yeah and now it's out great good job
that's exactly right
or any any of the the the locks that we
put around at any of the the protocols
we've built to keep it in place I think
if you were about to say it's super
intelligent so by definition it's
smarter than basically all of us
combined right it's like say it's like
saying it's like a it's like a dog
believing it can lock you in a room
right forever right it's like no you say
oh I just bought it you know 14 ounce
t-bone steak you want a free dinner yeah
yeah yeah well I have to go prepare it
then they open the door I get out of the
door okay right and better than yeah
better than that I think okay you're
gonna have to forgive me because you had
a you had a colleague on and he's a
teacher he might have been one of your
teachers that we talked to and one of
his methods for getting students to
learn is you give them the same problem
that some other astrophysicists may have
faced and then as they solve it that's
how they learn as opposed to teaching
them what that astrophysicists already
discovered you let them make the
discovery so if this thing is so smart
it would literally have the ability to
just whatever we design to go back to
square one and redesign it on its own I
say well now here's the next phase
that's how I get out of three well
that's that's one of the emerging
threats is AI machine learning that can
write code like I think some Harvard
researchers trained a deep learning
algorithm to write code any minute to
code learning deep this write deep
impact except deep impact because Morgan
Freeman is delightful as the president
the United States absolutely did the
asteroid win in that one I never saw it
it it tied took out New York City yeah
okay but California civilization endured
that's what matters
okay so then that asteroid was not an
existential it was except we split it
into two uh-huh and the big piece went
away in the end in the end of the movie
well you have to destroy any work cuz
it's a movie but but they did it right
rather than unlike in Armageddon where
the asteroid pieces had GPS locators and
hit monuments one decapitated the
Chrysler Building really okay and hit
the clock continued through the Chrysler
Building went in the front door of Grand
Central Terminal and here's the clock in
the middle of the floor okay okay
another one's came from over New Jersey
and hit the World Trade Center okay
that's aiming for our our stuff all
right so deep impact had science
advisors okay because because Armageddon
with Bruce Willis violates more known
laws of physics per minute than any
other movie ever made
okay so you know even more than than
gravity no no that one was cool that was
at least tried okay okay okay
that one tried but thanks for
remembering
by gravity tirade but you only get one
question in the second well listen this
has been I'm still entertained on one
question we're doing a great job the
world so we could fit in one short one
okay all right let's go with will J our
patreon patron who says this what one or
two skills would you learn now to be
useful and productive in a
post-apocalyptic world that is of course
if we survive the event so I got one
ready kill right ahead I would learn how
to break into a hardware store yeah
nothing more valuable in an apocalypse
than the contents of a hardware store or
a towel
don't forget your towel that's a
Hitchhiker's Guide
I just got hitchhiked to break into a
hardware store my my answer would be
learning how to collect canned food that
would be mine that's it that's that
movie the boy and his dog understood the
Don Johnson Don Johnson yeah yeah the
dog was intelligent and but the dog
would help Dante apocalyptic earth okay
and it's a boy his door the only ones
alive on Earth's surface as far as they
know and Don Johnson he's like the
teenager in this movie he's literally a
teenager as an actor and he's playing a
young kid boy and his dog so the dog
helps him find food but the food is all
canned and the dog can't get into the
can so he opens the cans and they both
eat buddy it's it's it's a and so they
both and the dog I think it communicates
telepathically to him or something now
it's an intelligent dog is it possible
Don Johnson is just nuts in that movie
and the no no no no it turns out then
it'd be a doctor it turns out there is
in this movie the civilization still
exists but they all went underground
okay okay and he learns this and it
turns out when they go underground all
the men become sterile okay so all the
women when they want to propagate the
species have to get sperm from only
people men who are above ground from Don
John is it a sexy movie no not really
Cinemax at 3:00 a.m.
skinemax no no all right so all right so
Chuck what would you what would you beat
we were one thing you would take with
you
skill one skill it would be this being
funny because everybody loved it I'll be
like dude you know give somebody laugh
and they were like one other thing
there's one more skill you have to have
okay
thou shalt know physics all right okay
if you know physics just move back into
the cave it's kind of a superpower
here's that some reason why I thought
about that recently I was asked to
review a book written by some MIT
physicists and engineers okay and it's
called the physics of energy the physics
of energy just came out god oh that
looks like a textbook it is kind of a
textbook okay yeah it's based on courses
they taught I okay the physics of energy
Robert Jaffe Washington Taylor and so I
actually blurbed the book even books
like this you can get blurbs I couldn't
put it down
there goes ready all right here go buy
one textbook this year if your task was
to jumpstart civilization but had access
to only one book then the physics of
energy would be your choice Wow
professors Taylor and Jaffe have written
a comprehensive thorough and relevant
treatise it's an energizing read as a
standalone book but it should also be a
course offered at every college lest we
miss manage a collective role as
shepherds of our energy hungry energy
dependent civilization sweet drop have
anything to do with the with the chap
that I see sitting on this table here
from Taylor engine no that was just to
cover the postage Oh so the point is you
don't want to have to wait for another
Isaac Newton to be born to discover the
physics and then you want to you want to
start where you left off so and so
that's what
this book would do cool that was a
really good answer yeah better than a
towel I think I mean food I don't mean
to besmirch no it's alright you know
Douglas Adams here but it was a jokey
answer so well we just end that segment
we're gonna come back to more cosmic
queries on the end of the world as we
know it we're back on Startalk I'm Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist today's special cosmic
queries edition on the ends of the world
and we've got Josh Clark with us Josh
hey welcome thank you you're the stuff
you should know guy yes that's right
with a new podcast ends of the world
yeah the end of the world with Josh
Clark appropriately and really want to
associate your name with like the Tyler
Perry of science podcast pretty much
yeah that's what I was going for and
listen it's a smart thing to do everyone
who worked on it I made sign a contract
that said they would not look me in the
eye during but it's a it's all about
existential risks and it's largely based
on the work of a guy named Nick Bostrom
who is of Oxford Oxford he's basically
been warning people about existential
risks for 20 years and is really kind of
giving us our understanding of what
existential risks are and why they're
different and why they're worth paying
attention I said I know him I know his
work I've not met him yeah but I've
referenced his work many times in my
talks I got to speak to him a few times
for the podcast like three times and on
the third time his his assistant was
like you know dr. boström like puts
every request for like a media
appearance or an interview or a project
or whatever through a cost-benefit
analysis and I made it through that
grinder like three times and I felt
pretty good about that billion downloads
has something to do with the billion
it's a heavy number I think the reason
why he was speaking to me so frequently
you're so willing to talk to me about
the same thing three times is because
you know he was talking through me who's
trying to reach more people and that
kind of brought me back down inside a
little bit after
realize that that's a good thing though
I mean you know it's worthwhile yeah
yeah so Chuck just get some more credits
do ya any more patreon hmm no but I God
here it is so this is fill Vader 23 from
Instagram somewhat rhetorical but I'm
I'm I'm interested I think I know why he
asked if the world ended with the human
race end and I'll say vice-versa
there are there are a lot of people who
feel like that this is like we're it who
you know what I mean like if we end that
is the end like so if the world ended
with the human race end and if the human
race ends we we know the world wouldn't
end but earth is gonna be here with or
without us yeah
Luther's here before during and after
asteroid strikes it's here before during
and after viral viral attacks so we are
a blip in the history of the earth so
when people say oh save earth they
usually mean save ourselves on earth in
almost every case somebody says save
earth that's implicitly what they mean
save humans on earth you might say Oh
save the other animals they might say
that that what they mean is what we are
doing is affecting other animals and
ultimately that might affect us because
we're in a we're in a ecosystem that has
balance and interconnectivity so it's
the shortsightedness of decisions we
make
let me not call it's short-sighted let
me say not fully researched no because I
think people think they're doing what's
okay right they thought let's make a
smokestack and pump smoke into the air
right so that it goes into the air high
above you rather than a ground level
that's better right and no one is
thinking well this is still in the air
and it's wrapping around the earth you
know so air pollution was not imagined
that it would ever be a worldwide
problem right and so we have to learn
that and when we did we've made great
progress all right I mean air is cleaner
than has ever been
all around the world Thank You Al Gore
he invented clean air so yeah this end
of the earth thing I do talk much about
the end of the earth I do it was it's a
it's a big point that I make that if we
if we screw up and we like wipe
ourselves out whether it's through AI or
some biotech accident or maybe something
going awry with nanotech or a physics
experiment even potentially if we do
this he's trying to drink my people in
today I was waiting for I thought I
would get out of that I considered it
but then decided no but if we if we if
the worst comes and we slip up and we
wipe ourselves out life would almost
almost certainly go on because it has so
many times before we've been through at
least five that we know of mass
extinctions big ones too I think the
Ordovician one I can't remember how long
ago it was it was very very ancient but
they're starting to think that a
gamma-ray burst basically sterilized
earth came that close to just killing
all life on Earth and it still couldn't
a gamma-ray burst hit earth and life
still hung on hung on after the asteroid
wiped out the dinosaurs and a lot of
other species life will probably keep
going I would bet just about anything on
it so yeah there will be life after
after we go if we go if we go to us the
world will evented so it is kind of moot
in that respect hmm um so one thing
about the gamma-ray burst is that was
invoked after no one could find any
other reason for how that many how much
life is that right yeah I mean it's it's
plausible and we have them in the
universe yeah usually they're pointing
in some other direction or if they point
towards us they're very far away so the
question is in the statistics of this
could you have one that's nearby that
points straight at us and if it does
these are high-energy particle of
high-energy light and it first takes out
the ozone layer right the ozone protects
you until there's no ozone right but it
keeps coming so it's like the first line
of defense that is now all massacred now
it keeps going makes it all the way
to Earth's surface and those are
high-energy particles it is is
incompatible with the large molecules
that we call biology nice oh just breaks
apart your molecule right and it kills
everything it'll kill everything if
you're in a cave you'll survive but you
probably eat things that dependent on
things that died on Earth's surface
so would you survive even with that
atmosphere burned away take out the
ozone so you'd have to go to places
where you'd still be protected okay bye
from the ozone which would be
underground yeah you would really like
episode 4 which is about natural risks
including gamma-ray bursts and now in
the end you'd be very proud I conclude
that they are quite rare and probably
not going to happen yeah rare enough so
that really you should like do things
like buckle your seat belt right but but
you can't take care of both you can take
care of immediate threats like dying in
a car crash while you're simultaneously
thinking about more remote larger
threats as well and but in proportion
you do that in a in a balanced way sure
that is my new phrase now just for when
I'm going to have reckless abandon
just gamma life point you if you take a
90% of the life and 10% survives what
you've done is pry open ecological
niches that we're the 10% of the life
that remains can now to just run in
filters run fill that well you yeah you
can make a pretty good case that if we
are wiped out we would leave the biggest
ecological niche of all currently on
earth have you seen the book life after
man I saw like this special on out like
discovery or something maybe they made
that after the book they did so I
thought you were talking about a
lifetime special Christmas enlightenment
so if we so who do we keep trying to
kill that lives with us like the mice
and rats right right so if we're out of
the way what sets the upper size of a
mouse or a rat is that it can escape
from being killed by us by going to a
pipe or a hole if we're not there
nothing to stop the growth of rodent
which is like what's the name of the bar
that's it what's that against nothing
marry the copy bar that's rodent there
was this big
River rodent nothing nothing there's
nothing to stop so then they would just
run the world nice right
so but but that they'd have museums so
there there would also be nothing
stopping the capybaras or the giant
rodents from also gaining intelligence
it's possible that that we like to think
of ourselves as the only intelligent
life on earth and that's just patently
untrue we just have to expand our
definition of intelligence so perhaps
were the current endpoint in the
evolution of intelligent life on earth
but if we're gone that doesn't mean that
that evolution of intelligences gives
going to cease as well so maybe a
million years or 50 million years or 100
million years from now the capybaras
will be like exploring the the galaxy or
the universe but that presumes that
intelligent improve intelligence
improves your survival is a very big
assumption i but that is an assumption
of the cockroaches doing just fine mmm
without any kind of brain that we would
okay that's true but you can also
demonstrate that is freeing those
cockroaches if we take our intelligence
I don't know what you think when you see
a roach right when I see a roach I'm
really not thinking that's an
intelligent I'm really not thinking that
I'm sorry no you can be so intelligent
that you have devised ways of destroying
your own genetic lineage that is the
entire point of the podcast that I made
the end of the world josh clark that we
could possibly have become so
intelligent that we might accidentally
wipe ourselves out with that
intelligence this is my point so
therefore an intelligent copy bara might
not be where evolution takes it right
okay so let's say that that is that that
we're following not a predetermined or
prescribed process but just whatever its
head is probably going to follow within
a certain boundary and that we're kind
of in the middle of that boundary and
that the capybaras that came behind us
would follow the same path right there's
every reason to believe that if we wipe
ourselves out the capybaras will wipe
themselves out too and that goes to
inform another thing that I go into in
the podcast what's called the great
filter this idea that it's possible that
there is some barrier between the origin
of life growing into intelligent life
and that intelligent life spreading out
into the universe and that that is why
we seem to be alone in the universe
because the humans and the capybaras
will always inevitably destroy
themselves probably because of their
intelligence because they gain as Sagan
put it they became more powerful before
they became wise that's a very that's a
precarious position being and that's
it's the position that we're in right
now it's called adolescence energy to
act but without the wisdom to to
constrain it right so there's a version
of what you said which surely you know
about because it would have been in that
same world of research that you did it
has to do with alright let's say we want
to colonize that's a bad word today
settle another planet show it show up
let's say we want to take a big case so
what happens so maybe you go out to the
plant and then okay
what's the urge that made you want to do
that well it's an urge to like explore
okay mhm or to conquer mhm
either it's the same effect now the
people there who want to do the same
thing you've read this into your genetic
line because you you having babies and
you're the one who wanted to do this so
then they get to planets and then they
have babies and they get to play go one
two four eight sixteen it is suggested
that you can reach a point where the
very urge to explore necessarily is the
urge to conquer thereby preventing the
full exploration of the galaxy because
you're gonna run into somebody gonna run
into your own people on people correct
right correct and that is a
self-limiting arc that's that's the Borg
I mean you know yeah but the thing is
the the great filter in particular which
is
an economist a physicist turned
economist named Robin Hanson who I'm
sure you know no I don't know okay well
Robin Hanson came up with this idea that
there's there's something that stops
life from expanding out into the planet
and the reason why it would seem to stop
before they expand out from their
planets because we would see evidence of
them otherwise by now
well it's that the Fermi paradox right
yeah yeah which is episode another
question all right here we go let's keep
gonna be fast cuz we're almost out of
this segment all right let me take you
somewhere and answer these questions
because no it's good I like all right
you know I'm go deep dive DJ Mass 2006
from Instagram says how do you want to
die Chuck knows how I wanted that cuz I
want to I want to fall into a black hole
that's it yeah that's a good one yeah
that's a good one that's totally good
good lord so can I can I follow up with
a question okay would you know that you
have fallen into a black hole we would
know in advance that that's what I want
to do then I'd fall in right and then I
would watch what happened and report
back until my signal never gets out of
the black hole and I get is if you're in
the black hole would it is it is it a
process that would allow you some
consciousness at a level where you would
be like oh my until you've ripped apart
but you're conscious of everything as
you fallen even through the event
horizon through the event horizon you
would still be calm
oh yes yes and you'll see the whole
thing Wow totally cool how about you I
was gonna say quickly and painlessly is
how I want to do not imagine it to you
just in case you know inion about what
people don't know you better answer them
okay all right fine fine how do I want
to die I don't know I think a low energy
vacuum bubble would be pretty cool just
washing over us all of a sudden which
would probably be quick and painless but
then you it would happen at the speed of
light so you wouldn't see it coming
quick and painless that's another quick
and painless yeah wears a black hole is
quick but very painful but deeply
fascinating because you get spaghetti
fine you would feel that oh yeah okay
that's what I was all right when we come
back more star talk cosmic queries
on the end of the world as we know it so
our talk is back
I got Josh Clark with me who is as a new
podcast on the ends of the world because
he wasn't happy with the billion
downloads of stuff you should know he's
still at it so glad to have you on the
show thank you so we're doing it's a
cosmic queries edition and Chuck we
spent so much time answering only a few
questions yes we got to make this whole
segment of lightning round okay so let's
just do it we have never done this
before the entire which means that you
have to answer the question as concisely
as possible soundbite you okay dr. niko
blat 247 on instagram says when we find
life off of the earth would you expect
how would you expect religious groups to
react would they change thanks from
illinois right go they would freak out i
think some religious groups would freak
out because life on earth human life on
earth intelligent human life on earth is
the belief to be the sole creation of
god but so many other religious groups
will be totally down with it and just
see it as a greater part of god's
creation all right Bing Bing let's move
on this is Liam Beckett on Instagram who
says this do you think as a society we
will ever get past biased news from both
sides or only become more divided
speaking of the end of the world yeah
totally I think this is just kind of
like a temporary problem that we have
and we are going to continue to advance
and as we advance we will be less
divided that's my hope at least Neil was
beautiful that was unrealistically
beautiful this is just a phase we're
going through really it's not the
beginning of the end of civilization my
issue is people try to beat each other
on the head to convince them of your own
opinion and try to get you to vote in
ways that align with your opinion when
there's so much
so many things out there that are
objectively true that we should all
agree on what is objectively true and
then base civilization on that and then
after that celebrate each other's
diverse opinions rather than beat each
other over the head for them being
different but I think that's a point
that we're we can conceivably get to and
when we do we will be less divided so
really you just said the same thing I
did all right all right next question
this is Francesco Sante says as long as
humans have existed I assume we have
looked up and felt the connections with
the universe even if we didn't have the
insights of astrophysics and cosmology
do our atoms know all caps that they
came from up there no no so so John
Kennedy I think before President Kennedy
before he was president as you may know
he they have a home in Hyannisport
really so the ocean coastline is not
unfamiliar to him they own boats this
sort of thing he spoke often about the
allure of the ocean and wondered openly
whether we are drawn to the ocean shore
because our genetic profile may remember
that in fact they came our vertebrate
history is owed to the fishes in the sea
and that we're somehow pulled back to it
so I can I can poetically agree with
that but there is no way we could have
known that we are Stardust without
modern astrophysics telling us this I
think we will look up and wonder but I
don't think it's because there's a
genetic connection I think it's because
we just want to know if someone up there
gonna eat us we look up at the universe
the way you look in the brush there's
something there gonna harm me if it's
not then otherwise it's a beautiful
thing to look at hmm interesting
okay next Alejandra Hernandez once from
Twitter says this with some a I nearly
capable of passing the Turing test do
you believe the technological
singularity will occur in the near
future and if so how do you
Thank You manatee welfare now we touched
upon that in the so let me sharpen that
question here it is how soon is this
gonna happen there you go oh I don't
know may I be our overlord this thing
that I find upsetting and scary is that
the man who has an end of the world
podcast yes
what I find scary I'm afraid now it
could happen at any time conceivably it
could happen at any time from what I
understand we have all the components
out there and it could just kind of
happen they could fall into place I
don't know it's impossible to predict
when it will happen and you can't say
with absolute certainty that it will
happen it's just really possible and the
fact that it is possible means that it
could conceivably happen at any time and
is the cell phone is that I'm sorry is
the singularity this is my question so
we're still in art our lightning round
is the singularity actual consciousness
or is it self-aware so the singularity
is this point where machines become
self-aware and super intelligent or if
you're a transhumanist that's the point
where we murdered with a transhumanist
yeah what is that so that's a big big
umbrella term in it it encompasses a lot
of different thoughts and philosophies
but the main thing that threads it all
together is this idea that we can and
will and should merge with our machines
merge with our technology which sounds
far out until you realize already doing
it yeah we wear like glasses and
contacts and clothes and stuff like that
can I carry the internet in my pocket
yes exactly now I don't have to graft it
into my cerebellum okay but wouldn't it
be easier and more convenient if you did
just kind of get information that
rapidly they open skull surgery or pull
this out of my pocket is that my choice
basically I don't need to see the latest
cat video that badly I can wait until I
can dial it up on my on my phone but
what about an infinite loop of cat video
well next question okay here we go
Rex Jung you almost touched on this but
from Twitter says this Rex wants to know
any general advice on how to foster
peace in
the world locally online or in the world
at large how do we foster and foment
peace that was then preclude if you
succeed at that that means total
worldwide warfare is off the table as an
existential risk
yeah that's an important question right
right so yeah I think that um that seems
to be found in the organizations and the
institutions that we build from what I
understand the the the moral progress of
humanity has been kind of tied to the
the global community that we've been
developing and as we spread out and
understand and meet more and more people
and connect with more and more people
that seems to be in lockstep with with
this movement toward peace on a glowkies
Gail
he's so hopeful I really am hopeful I
I'm deeply hopefully a man I'm also
worried but I am hopeful for sure wow
that's really cool I wish I was that
ready I'm not that hopeful if I were
that hopeful I'd be unemployed chance of
making it to technological maturity and
safety but I'm deeply hopeful that we
will and that if we do reach that that
there will be a much more peaceful
species that we are all right cool I
don't know how much time were you going
to do it do it this is fired our Popoff
via door with Fyodor Theodore Theodore
but not Theodore Theodore Theodore mater
that's the original hey here we go what
do you think are the best ways to keep
abreast of current developments in the
study of existential risk there are
great websites out there like those of
future humanity Institute and future of
life Institute Li there is very active
on social media
have you ever specifically researched
the various topics you've explored since
you've finished the series yeah actually
great questions so a couple of things
I'm planning on doing a follow-up to the
the end of the world podcast these first
10 episodes that's a lot more podcasting
a weekly kind of thing to keep abreast
of all this stuff so listen out for that
but also the future of life in
stitute actually is pretty pretty pretty
visible on social media they have a
great podcast as well but that that's a
really important point right now as far
as existential risks are concerned
there's a lot of academics writing
really smart papers and you have to go
grind those up to understand what's
going on so that's one of the reasons
why I Demick we've read the papers right
academic research papers are very dry
right and very jargon Phil yeah and
they're really hard you have to teach
yourself how to read an academic paper
so it is a grind for people like us
right so that's why I made this podcast
and that's why I I plan to continue to
make the podcast because I will grind
this stuff up and then try to explain it
so that it's not just a canoe be our
conduit to our extinction that way I get
bored so you don't have to here's this
one this is Mr Mario Gert
Mario court on Instagram says is it
possible that our universe is someone
else's Large Hadron Collider what
awesome little question I mean are we
the galaxies on the belt of Orion right
there you go
did you get that reference no hmm men
implying a black the first one yes you
have you have incomplete geek street
cred there's things that I need to learn
some yeah some guy that's okay we still
love you so let me answer that in a
slightly different way okay when we
first probe the atom and we found oh
wait a minute the Anam has a nucleus and
it's got electrons that orbit the
nucleus that's just like the solar
system it's whole series just like the
galaxy mm-hmm
where the star is orbiting the center of
the galaxy we have planets orbiting a
star
we have electrons orbiting so maybe it's
that all the way down maybe that's the
theme and maybe that's how all this
works and when you start probing the
atom on that scale the laws of physics
manifest in completely different ways
right so it's not just a scaling
phenomenon right so for us to have these
laws of physics manifest the way that we
do and claim that it's the microscopic
physics and someone else's Collider it's
just not a realistic extension of how
things work
hmm although it was deeply attractive
because it was philosophically pleasing
to imagine that you just had nested
quartz because it's like it just nesting
it's just you just keep going oh right
so so because things manifest
differently on these scales you can't
just get for example okay there's a
something called a water Strider which
is a an insect that can just draw all
the water yeah it's use a surface
tension of the water if that were any
bigger it would just fall through you
can't you can't scale things because the
forces operating have different
manifestations on different scales
that's why and so that's why what's the
movie them movies oh he's got one I had
seen that he's got one it's on giant
ants I thought he was some nuclear thing
and the ants got big nice ants are
coming okay answer creepy anyway and now
they're bigger than you yeah you freaked
out that can never happen because ants
have these tiny spindly little legs
right and if you scale up the size of
the ant its weight outstrips the ability
of these spindly legs to hold them up
have you done this on Twitter have you
have you done a Twitter random by good I
could totally rant so the point is as
you get bigger I can say this
mathematically right as you get bigger
the strength of your legs your limbs
only goes up as the cross-sectional area
but your weight goes up as the cube of
your dimensions oh so what happens is
because as you get bigger you
in all dimensions but your legs if you
let gets wider the strength is only the
cross-section of your Latin right you
just crush off
that's why hippopotami don't have skinny
legs right they're sort but elephants
have some pea legs right okay
giraffe has long slender legs your
effort and not don't weigh all that much
it's slanted and the distribution is
distribution is complete if I can so
it's so it's a fascinating cottage
industry and studying the relationship
between size and life and how things and
how things scale that was really cold
it's why if you take a bucket of water
and empty it on your car it doesn't stay
as a big ball of water but if the make
the water smaller and smaller and
smaller
it just becomes droplet it's a drop in
the drop will stay on the because
surface tension holds it certain is not
strong enough to hold big things and
hold a little thing right the world of
insects is completely surface driven
their physics courses in insects one is
all about surface tension huh right yeah
because they do get trapped inside of a
little bubble how do I get out everybody
needs even name say we got a rafter so
that was cool that was cool we gotta
wrap this oh yeah we did get a bunch in
there that was that was like the longest
lightning round we've ever yeah good
good good so Josh thanks thanks for
coming on thank you so much for you got
to do this again I will do it anytime
you want anytime that we'll walk up here
for the from where do you live down in
Atlanta Atlanta just before we sign off
tell us exactly where to find your work
oh you can find the end of the world
with josh clark anywhere you find
podcasts including the iHeartRadio app
and Apple podcasts and all that jam and
then you can find me on social media at
Josh um Clark is on if you noticed
enough I say I'm quite a bit and I
started a hashtag to keep a conversation
about existential risk going it's
hashtag yo TW Josh
so people can find me those ways all
right if you're looking for the end of
the world this is your man
so dude thanks for be honest are thank
you very much Chuck always good to have
you how you kiddin me it's my pleasure
all right you've been listening to
possibly even watching Startalk end of
the world as you know it edition from
cosmic queries Josh Clark thanks for
being on thank you as always I bid you
to keep looking up